all right Tim Farriss here playing with
dry ice that I received in my Omaha
Steaks box didn't know what to do so I
sent a tweet out to my readers in Rob
Knight told me to experiment as he did
it as a science teacher with room
temperature coins and dry ice so I could
have groove into the ice with my Kershaw
Assist open knife and you can see here
vibrates like that Hillary to hold a
pencil so it's it's freezing cold be
careful you don't freeze these to your
fingers like I did a minute ago well if
I take a warm coin I can press it listen
to this
hold and then it stops thought it was
air vibrations but I think as [ __ ]
something to do with the temperature so
let's try a different approach I have a
cup of reasonably warm water here Wow
don't do that and then I'm going to grab
a piece of dry ice here oh this is not
as refined as mr. science you drop that
in then you have instant fog look at
that how cool is that and if you look
inside I'll try to show you guys this
all the boiling bubbles are white which
is pretty sweet so you have instant fog
machine in your house and then what's
really cool which I did has a very
interesting visual effect is you slowly
pour it out so watch this it's not half
as cool looking at it from that
perspective but it's pretty neat to pour
it out the sink then you have all this
fog throughout the house that's my
indoor atrium over there I'll show you
that while we're doing this as you can
see I have more or less than rainforest
20 to 30 feet of plants in there so I
can oxygenate and that's the end of our
science show for this evening thanks
readers blood blood blood blood blood